i can the women get to stay at home it's
all fun but it's not all fun and games a
lot of those women are abused they're
treated like crap like that but why are
they controlled but why is that your
immediate like like i just don't
understand why that's your immediate gut
reaction is to say like they're at home
because they're controlled and they're
abused and all that stuff like i know
what i'm asking is that is that your
your view on men it's just that you
think the majority of men are like
abusing their women no but i think a lot
of those women are unhappy and it comes
from the old school days like where
they're actually suppressed and they're
kind of talk they're brought into that
tradition and it just continues where a
lot of those women actually are unhappy
and they would like to speak out and
vomiting like if your mum raised you
like yo don't chase [ __ ] from no man
like you would move completely different
cultures
she says all this culture i'm like it
depends on like who you've been raised
by like some families invite this that's
right that's where xenia was like that's
where race comes into ethnicity a lot of
those things come like they're big
factors like we can all talk about the
positivity but there are other sides
like we're here to have a discussion on
all those different types of views so we
can't just say oh like yeah there's all
those women are happy but not all those
women are happy we're not there's
nothing that happens
how do you like why is that your
assumption how do you know we don't but
that is but you also see it from